Note that like in any analysis process, the conclusions that we reach are always
tentative. As we engage in the process, we learn more about the problem,
which may lead to revisions of our analysis. In fact, it was one of the early
lessons of software engineering, is that requirements documents are always wrong
in the sense that they're incomplete, or inconsistent, or they don't truly
reflect what it is that the customer ultimately wants. And as an analyst it's
your job to elicit that correct description. And OOA can help you do that.
Questions that arise during OOA may require research on your part,
or even going back to the customers. Often, the customers may not have even
considered, what you, what you bring up as a question. And will thank you for
realizing that there was more to the problem than what they originally had in my
mind. Thus, the overall process of analysis is inherently incremental,
hopefully leading to a joint understanding between the analyst and
customer so that the design and implementation can proceed